[Music]
hey guys today we're going to be talking
about one of my favorite books
and it's a book that's given me a whole
new perspective on the creative process
and it's called where good ideas come
from by stephen johnson
in this book he studies innovation from
a environmental perspective he studies
spaces that have led to innovation from
cities
to offices to coffee houses to
the internet and he identifies some
really interesting patterns
he also talks about how we can replicate
these environments in our own lives
which i'll cover at the end of the video
hey guys welcome back to the channel if
you're new here my name is jeremy
and i am a licensed architect in
beautiful vancouver bc
on this channel we talk about
architecture and creativity
and also some tools and strategies that
can help you have more meaningful
careers in architecture
so i used to think that the best ideas
come from deep
inside your head you know i would lock
myself in my room
and think really really hard and work
really really hard
and expect to come up with a genius
concept with this uh
in this eureka moment and i think our
society has
its role models for innovation um
as this solitary genius and our language
around innovation is all about that
aha moment you know like a flash
or a stroke of genius epiphany
the lightbulb moment this kind of shows
that
an idea is a single thing that happens
in a single moment but
what stephen johnson found is that ideas
happen
in a network and they happen over a
really long period of time
so he first talks about this idea of the
adjacent possible
which is the idea that at any moment in
time
a lot of different changes can happen in
the world but
only certain creations and certain
changes can happen
based on what's available in your
environment
so if you look at the primordial soup
things like
rhinos or iphones they would exist
outside of the few molecular reactions
that were possible
this book is full of really fun examples
but one of the ones that i like the most
is the story of the baby incubator
in the 19th century child mortality
rates
or infant mortality rates were like
insanely high compared to
our standards today like one in five
babies died
like very soon after birth and if
it was worse if they were a little
smaller so in the 1870s this
obstruction who are doctors who deliver
babies
called stefan turner he took a break
from his work
from the hospital and he took a little
walk to the zoo
at the zoo he saw some elephants he saw
some giraffes
and he like stumbled across this
exhibition
of chicken incubators and seeing these
cute little chickens chipping around in
the incubators
something sparked in his mind and he
actually ended up hiring
the poultry raiser from the zoo
to build a similar incubator for babies
and so long story short they actually
worked
before the incubators the mortality rate
of babies was 66
just within weeks of birth and after
being housed in these incubators that
was reduced to 38
so fast forward like 100 years these
incubators become really popular
and they evolved to include other
functions like
oxygen therapy in most western countries
pretty much
becomes a standard in most of the
hospitals
by the end of world war ii however in
developing countries
the infant mortality rates are still
really really high
the problem is that these machines have
become
very high functioning but also very
complicated and expensive
and it costs more than forty thousand
dollars
so whenever these things break down
hospitals in developing countries they
just don't have
the they didn't have the technical
expertise
um and they couldn't find the
replacement parts to
fix the machines and so this actually
was a really common problem
and studies have found that like 95
of medical technology that's been
donated to developing countries
they just break down within the first
five years this
organization called design that matters
had uh they've been trying to solve this
problem for years
what they found is that the only thing
that like even the smallest towns
in these developing countries seemed to
be able to keep running
were cars
they came up with an idea to create
these incubators
out of car parts which led to this
prototype called neo nurture so the
exterior looks really nice and modern
but the guts were all made up of like
headlights or dashboard fans like all
the very common
things that were inside a car and things
that
like a car mechanic could easily come
and replace
yeah so i thought this was a really
great example
like good ideas are more like this neo
nurture
you know we think of our ideas as these
like expensive 40 000
incubators but usually they're just put
together
with spare parts in your surroundings
or what steven johnson calls the
adjacent possible
but even with all these adjacent
possibilities without
the thing that brings them together you
couldn't actually
get a new idea and this connection
mechanism
is what mr johnson calls the liquid
network
he actually looks at how connections
happen
at multiple levels he looks at the
molecular level
he looks at it from the neurological
level and he also
zooms out and looks at it from a macro
level
at the scale of the city how
on how people meet and how people create
new ideas
in all these cases you need
a very very densely populated network
and you need a substance like a liquid
to facilitate the mixing of different
molecules or ideas
to create connections and compare to
a solid which will fix things in place
and a gas which will just scatter things
without
letting the molecule stick a liquid
network
allows you to constantly explore new
patterns
but it's also capable of preserving that
structure for a long period of time for
example when you look at the
explosion of ideas throughout history
it actually happened right after the
agricultural revolution
when thousands and thousands of people
for the very first time started
living together and yes you could argue
that there were inventions
before then that were just never
recorded
but um what he says is that's actually
the point
that when people were living in low
density and
nomadic tribes there was no structure or
time to record any of these findings and
this happens
because of what we call information
spillover
when you share the same civic spaces
with
thousands of other people good ideas
tend to just flow
from one mind to another even if the
creators
even if they try to keep it secret one
of the great examples of a liquid
network is
building 20. i talked about this
building
in detail in my other video if you want
to check that out
building 20 at mit was a rundown
temporary building built purely out of
necessity
but it's actually the building that led
to
some of the greatest innovations in the
last century
it was extremely dense they basically
packed
all the overflow students in that one
little building
it had kind of an accidental liquid
network because it was practically a
maze
people were constantly getting lost and
stumbling into different departments
which led to these random encounters
between people
but even if these people had crossed
paths
if they didn't already have some ideas
they were already working on
and if they didn't already have some
kind of knowledge in their fields
new ideas wouldn't be able to form
and this is what stephen johnson calls
the hunch which is
an inkling about an idea or an initial
thought about
an idea and he says a hunch needs to
connect
with another hunch to become a
full-fledged idea
and most hunches that turn into
important innovations happen over a long
period of time
he talks about this 18th century
scientist
called joseph priestley who
basically proved that plants were
creating oxygen
by isolating a
mint spring in a sealed glass and this
was one of the discoveries that
founded modern ecosystem science
and he was basically building on a hunch
that
he had cultivated like years and years
and years ago
back to when he was a kid apparently he
was really obsessed with
trapping spiders inside glass jars and
he
realized that something interesting was
happening when organisms
died when they were sealed in closed
environments that's sick bastard what
stephen johnson's trying to say here is
that
the scientists didn't pursue the single
idea
of why did spiders die during those 20
years
he dabbled in a lot of different fields
and
did a lot of different experiments in
his lab and
engaged in a lot of different
conversations with a lot of different
people
and only a tiny percentage of his time
was actually dedicated to
the plant the problem of the plant
respiration
and it was just kept in the back of his
mind
sustaining a slow hunch is less about
perspiration it's more about cultivation
you have to give the hunch enough
nourishment
and just keep it growing but what's
interesting is that when people tell the
story of their inventions
they are likely to shorten the time span
and
condense it down to this single moment
for example
when darwin talks about his breakthrough
in his theory of evolution
he describes it as this eureka moment
according to him he was reading a book
by
thomas malthus on october 9th in
1838 when
it just came to him but when howard
gruber who was a psychologist and a
historian
when he revisited darwin's notebooks
darwin was
known for taking extensive notes and
sketches on everything
[Music]
he saw that the solutions were already
laid out in the notebooks
uh long before that day and
darwin had written it all down um
like on the importance of variation and
the
connection between natural and
artificial selection
his thoughts about the competition among
different species for survival
he had described all of this in depth
and in fact exactly one year ago
he writes in his notebook and asks
whether every animal produces in course
of ages 10 000 varieties and those alone
preserved which are well adapted it's
just a matter of shifting a couple
formulas
he didn't notice this until a year later
all the solutions were there right in
front of him but it just hadn't clicked
until that night
and his first inkling began almost 10
years ago
when he was on an expedition to the
keeling islands
and on this trip he took notes
religiously
and this was one of the things that
darwin did really really well
he just took notes on everything
he was keeping notebooks full of
sketches of all of his findings and
ideas
i'm also guilty of excessive note-taking
sketching is such an important skill for
architects
and architecture students because it
helps us
very quickly iterate through different
ideas
and toss out the ones that are bad and
it helps us efficiently communicate our
ideas
to our colleagues before we start
bringing them
into the digital realm skillshare has
tons of great courses on sketching
and the one that i really like is urban
sketching by
peggy dean where she teaches you how to
sketch urban settings and also to
develop your own
sketching style i'm sure you've all
heard of skillshare by now
it's an online learning community with
thousands of inspiring classes
where you can explore new skills or
refine existing ones like
photography sketching or graphic design
and because the classes are under 60
minutes with
short lessons it can fit any schedule
it's perfect for working professionals
like myself
and also for busy students it's also
curated specifically for learning
meaning there's no ads and they're
always launching
new premium classes also it's
less than ten dollars a month with an
annual subscription that's less than a
meal
the first 1 000 of my subscribers to
click the link with the description
will get a free trial of the premium
membership so you
can start learning on your own
you don't reach serendip by plotting a
course for it
you have to set out in good faith for
elsewhere and lose your bearings
serendipitously
but serendipity is not just about
embracing random encounters for the
excitement of it
serendipity is yes it is built out of
happy accidents but what makes them
happy is the fact that
the discovery that you made is
meaningful to you
in some way it completes a hunch
or opens up a door in the
adjacent possible that you hadn't
thought of before
but it's not truly serendipitous unless
it helps you
fill a piece of the puzzle that you've
been pouring over
serendipity needs these surprising
collisions
and discoveries but it also needs
something to anchor
those discoveries one of the inventions
that came out of building 20
is both corporations founded by ammar
bose
who was an electrical engineer he would
procrastinate
from writing his thesis and one day he
stumbled into the acoustics labs
which was just down the hall and
you know bose loved music and actually
before stumbling into the acoustics lab
he had bought a hi-fi he
bought the one with the best specs but
he was just really frustrated with the
sound quality
so um he'd been already thinking about
how he could improve it
so when he started talking to the
acoustic students he was able to connect
some of the dots of the
thoughts that had already been forming
in his mind
and he ended up creating this
wedge-shaped speaker
and that would later found the bose
corporation
the thing about serendipity for me is
that
it's inherently non-linear it forces you
to
break out of the confines of your
research
and explore other areas and see things
from a different
perspective which i think is very very
important
for breakthroughs i i kind of wanted to
talk about how i've used serendipity in
my own work
uh but this video is actually getting
pretty long
so i'm sure you guys are losing interest
so stay tuned
i will make another video for that
so last but not least stephen johnson
also makes some recommendations on what
we can do
to create serendipitous connections in
the
personal space of our mind as well as
within larger
institutions and also across
information networks in our societies in
the mind
you can go for a walk you can shower yes
shower please shower
yeah just remove yourself from your
task-based environment and take a walk
some of the greatest creators in history
have described
walking as an essential routine that
helps their productivity
and creativity and it's healthy i
actually recently took a course called
learning how to learn and the instructor
dr barbara oakley she actually has a
scientific term
for the state that your brain goes into
when it's relaxed
and it's called the diffuse mode of
thinking
and the best way to comprehend and
remember the information that you just
learned about is to
focus for several hours called the focus
mode
and take a break and just let your brain
simmer what you just learned
and that's called the diffuse mode you
could also take a reading vacation
the problem with trying to assimilate
new ideas
within your daily routine is that the
potential combinations or
the connections are limited by the reach
of your memory so for example if it
takes two weeks for you to finish a book
by the time you get to the next book you
might remember
like the broad strokes but you've
probably forgotten
a lot of the details which makes it hard
to cross-reference and mix the different
perspectives of the different authors
so one way around this is to carve out
dedicated
times where you collect the material you
wanted to read or learn
throughout the year and just read a
large
chunk of different types of books and
essays in a
condensed amount of time by compressing
this intake into
just a few days you give new ideas
the opportunity to connect simply
because it's easier to remember what you
read just a couple days ago than what
you'd read
like six months ago this is also what
cal newport suggests
in his book deep work i also made a
video on that if you want to check it
out i'll leave the link here
and i think that's why so many great
ideas and projects come
out of the thesis project because you
get to dedicate
a full year or two to just reading
tons of books and other research i also
have some tips and tricks on how to
remember everything you read
so make sure you check that out if
that's something you're interested in
in organizations i think it will be so
valuable if they encouraged employees to
take time
off work for learning new skills or
information
apparently google gives engineers one
day a week
to work on anything they want and
apparently almost half of their profit
generators
are from these independent projects
at the societal level the internet is
really the best tool for connections but
according to steven johnson
the way that we use it by filtering out
like
99.9 of the irrelevant information
it can sometimes take away the
serendipitous aspect of
the internet anyways that's it i hope
you guys found that interesting
this is one of those books that i will
just pick up and read
over and over again from time to time
because it's just like really inspiring
and it's full of fun anecdotes and
i feel like i take away something new
every time i read it so if you're
interested in reading the full book i'll
leave the link in my description
if you're interested in book reviews and
the creative process
i have another video where i talk about
the book deep work
by cal newport where he breaks down some
of the skills
that's going to make you really valuable
in the
digital world so check that out
and and i'll see you guys in the next
video
[Music]
bye
you